mit der Vorfreude ist es dieses Jahr so
eine Sache soll man sich auf Weihnachten
freuen angesichts der Pandemie und soll
man sich auf die Ampelkoalition freuen
angesichts der organisierten
Unzuständigkeit der deutschen Politik
den Aufbruch jetzt nicht nur
anzukündigen sondern zu praktizieren
dazu gehört vor allem eines Mut neues
Team neue Pläne Ampelkoalition auf der
Zielgeraden jetzt in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
zunächst hier im Studio Albrecht von
Lucke Politikwissenschaftler und
Redakteur bei den Blättern für deutsche
und internationale Politik auch unter
anderem wegen der Phoenix Runde haben
sie kaum noch einen freien Abend aber
wegen der politischen Ereignisse wird
ihre Expertise ganz einfach gebraucht
Alexander Kissler auch bei uns öfter zu
Gast Redakteur im Berliner Büro der
Neuen Zürcher Zeitung und zugeschaltet
sind Jana Wolfs Parlaments
Korrespondentin der Rheinischen Post
hier in Berlin und schließlich Heiner
torbock Personalberater und Headhunter
von Lucke Mut braucht die Politik das
wird jetzt der Ampelkoalition nicht
anders gehen war eigentlich das
Infektionsschutzgesetz gegen die
corona-pandemie letzte Woche Bundestag
war das eigentlich die Gesellen oder die
Meisterprüfung der Ampelkoalition
wenn es ich würde gerade sagen wenn es
wenigstens eine Gesellenprüfung war das
ist das was meinen Mut oder sagen wir es
mal den vorfreudigen Mut auch sehr
mindert ich würde sagen mit größerer
Schwäche und angeschlagenheit vor allem
einem Fehlen von klarer Führung und dem
Eindruck dass sie souverän in dieses
regieren startet mit größerem
Ballast ist selten eine Koalition
gestartet und deswegen glaube ich das
was wir alle vielleicht uns erhoffen Mut
Leidenschaft führungsvermögen bisher hat
sie es ein Stück weit vermissen lassen
und ich hoffe dass sie nicht sofort von
einer Sicht dramatisch zuspitzenden
coronakrise noch härter wieder eingeholt
wird gut Leidenschaft und
führungsvermögen das werden wir heute im
Laufe der Sendung noch vertiefen Frau
Wolf allerdings hat ja auch die Merkel
Regierung sich mit ihrer corona-politik
nicht wirklich einen guten Abgang
verschafft
das stimmt und daraus könnte man dann
schließen wenn man es einmal gut meint
mit denen künftig und noch Regierenden
dass es eben nicht nur an der
Führungskompetenz Führungsstärke liegt
sondern schon auch an den Umständen und
da kommen eben zwei sehr kritische
Sachen zusammen nämlich dass wir
einerseits eine vierte Welle haben die
dramatisch eskaliert und andererseits in
dieser ja unsicheren wagensituation
zwischen zwei Regierungen sind
ich glaube die ampelparteien die sind
noch nicht im Amt Scholz ist noch nicht
als Kanzler gewählt und die scheidende
Regierung hat eben nicht mehr kann nicht
mehr weitreichende Entscheidungen
treffen weil sie einfach bald nicht mehr
im Amt sind sofern
es ist vielleicht auch gut die Situation
mitzubedenken ohne dazu milde im Urteil
zu sein
Kistler der Nachteil der Demokratie ist
die notorische Feigheit von Politikern
vor dem Souverän das hat heute ein
Kollege von uns geschrieben
lernt eigentlich niemand das
Ignoranz unter den Teppich kehren
Verantwortung abschieben nicht
verantwortlich sein wollen dass das
Desaster noch vergrößert hier jetzt doch
Impfpflicht möglicherweise noch mals
Lockdown ist das Land die Politik nie
wir werden momentan nicht gut regiert
das würde ich auch so unterstreichen ich
würde die Verantwortung noch momentan
deutlich stärker bei der noch
amtierenden geschäftsführenden
Bundesregierung deponieren wollen wir
haben nur eine Bundesregierung wir haben
eine Bundeskanzlerin wir haben ein
Bundesgesundheitsminister Frau Merkel
und Herrn Spahn die machen ihren Job
momentan nicht gut was Ihre Frage angeht
ja die Verantwortung ist generell ein
ein Gut das in der Politik leider nur in
ganz ganz kleinen Dosen ausgeteilt wird
weil wann soll man sich denn gegen den
Souverän verantworten in Wahlen alle
vier Jahren und danach hat man Position
an die einem die Partei gestellt hat und
nicht unbedingt direkt der der Politik
der der Souverän das Volk insofern haben
wir nur eine sehr abgemilderte
Verantwortung und ich glaube wir werden
deshalb auch auf so schlecht regiert
weil diese Kultur der Verantwortlichkeit
fehlt
Herr doborg Kompetenz und Führung das
sind ja die Bedingungen für
erfolgreiches Management in Wirtschaft
und auch in Politik das ist so nicht nur
weil sie so definiert haben sondern weil
das ja auch für alle Bereiche gilt wenn
Sie sich jetzt die corona-krise das
aktuellste was wir in der Politik
sozusagen anzubieten haben ansehen ist
dass
Personal das politische Personal diesen
Maßstäben die ich da gerade zitiert habe
wenigstens annähernd gerecht geworden
also vorab für mich gehören zusammen
Kompetenz und Persönlichkeit
und wenn wir uns die oder ich habe mir
die Kanzlerkandidaten ja vorher
angeschaut und ich muss Ihnen sagen ich
habe noch nie eine so enttäuschende
Runde gesehen wie bei dieser
Bundestagswahl und wenn ich jetzt sehe
dass der designierte Kanzler
keine Emotionen zeigt keine Leidenschaft
zeigt der steht da und die Stimme ist
auf einer Ebene es geht wieder hoch es
geht wieder runter ist das jetzt alles
antrainiert will dann irgendwo anecken
will er smooth dadurch ich verstehe das
nicht wo ist die Persönlichkeit
aber man könnte jetzt ja könnte jetzt
aber auch sagen das ist ja genau das
Rollenmodell das Profil für das er
gewählt worden ist also er ist mit
dieser fast Immobilien Erscheinung
dieser monotonen Sprache dem fast
apathischen Körper gehst was ist er ja
kein Bundeskanzler geworden also
zumindest hat er seine Partei zu einem
relativ guten Ergebnis geführt und er
hat ja gerade diese Rolle des
unerschütterlichen der sich nicht
festlegen teste damit auch durch
verschiedene Krisen gekommen ist
perfektioniert also ich würde ihm
optimistischerweise vielleicht zutrauen
dass er im Amt etwas wächst und auch
noch etwas Leidenschaft vielleicht
entwickelt aber er wird in diesem Leben
nicht mehr charismatisch in die Rolle
des unerschütterlichen das hat er im
Wahlkampf gespielt offensichtlich
erfolgreich gespielt könnte es aber sein
dass er die Kurve nicht gekriegt hat
weil ja jetzt etwas anders gefordert ist
denn es fällt ja auf dass Olaf Scholz
sich bislang jedenfalls überall
zurückhält obwohl er ja demnächst unser
Bundeskanzler ist er ist gewählt worden
weil er die Rolle des unerschütterlichen
gespielt wo die These von Herrn Kissler
das ist ja eine sehr gut meinte Lesart
er ist deshalb gewählt worden und da
muss ich leider Herrn turbok voll
beipflichten weil es noch zwei
schlechtere Kandidaten gegeben hat und
das ist das eigentliche Drama wir haben
tatsächlich da muss man es leider erst
mal festhalten wahrscheinlich mit den
schwächsten Kandidaten die wir je hatten
in der bundesrepublikanischen Geschichte
zu tun gehabt und das in einer Zeit das
ist ein Kardinal schwacher Sieg wir
dürfen ja auch nicht vergessen dass
prozentual das ist ja auch ein Drama
dieser Koalition dass die SPD so schwach
ist als eine Kanzlerpartei mit 25%, wie
nie eine Partei zuvor war die ein
Kanzler gestellt hat dass eine grüne
Partei mit einer ziemlich versagenden
ziemlich noch gelinde gesagt
Kanzlerkandidatin beerbock 15 Prozent
erzielt hat also fast das denkbar
schlechteste um die klimawählerinnen und
Wähler die ja diesmal Kardinal dabei
waren abzuholen auch ganz schwach
letztlich und am besten vielleicht noch
eine FDP herausgekommen ist mit den zehn
gehaltenen Prozent aber das zeigt dass
wir es mit drei und das macht es so
dramatisch die Regierenden ja auch ganz
breit auseinanderdriftenden Kräften zu
tun haben das hat bereits corona-krise
im Angang gezeigt und wenn wir jetzt
eben erst mit einem Kanzler Scholz zu
tun bekommen bei dem ich mir ja
inständig hoffe dass es ihm gelingt eine
gewisse Leidenschaftlichkeit zu
entfachen die er Zeit seiner bisherigen
Biografie die wir alle sehr genau
verfolgt haben nie entfachen konnte wenn
ich das hoffen darf dann muss ich
trotzdem mal ein Pessimismus Ausdruck
verleihen dürfen dass ich es eigentlich
nicht erwarte und insofern glaube ich
dass in dieser Zeit wir tatsächlich
eigentlich zumindest eine Figur
bräuchten vom Schlager Schmidt wenn man
mal das Vorbild von von Olaf Scholz sein
wird der ist nicht am Markt und noch
weitergehend da wir sogar weit über den
Pragmatismus eines eines Helmut Schmidt
wahrscheinlich noch die Leidenschaft
eines Willy Brandt im besten Sinne für
die jahrhundertaufgaben bräuchten mit
den visionären Auskünften ist beides
gerade in der führungspartei SPD und das
ist mein Hauptproblem die Partei der SPD
muss Führung übernehmen und ein
kanzlerschutz ist weder das
leidenschaftliche visionäre
programmatisch vorhanden noch die
Autorität das ist das Problem diese
Hygiene von Helmut Schmidt und
willibrandia leider nicht eingefroren
also kann man jetzt auch nicht auftauen
und muss mit dem zurechtkommen was im
Moment zur Verfügung steht Frau Wolf es
wird ja von Aufbruch gesprochen in der
Ampel von fortschrittskoalition man hat
den Mund auch da ziemlich voll genommen
wenn wir noch mal auf die aktuelle
Corona Situation schauen in welche
Stimmung hinein bildet sich jetzt
eigentlich diese Ampelkoalition
möglicherweise wird ja morgen der
Koalitionsvertrag veröffentlicht und
spätestens 14 Tagen wird Olaf Scholz zum
Bundeskanzler gewählt in welche Stimmung
hinein entwickelt sich diese Koalition
jetzt auf der Zielgeraden
eine extrem angespannte ich glaube das
muss man gar nicht so sehr
ausbuchstabieren weil das jeder in
seinem eigenen Umfeld momentan erlebt
und die politische Diskussion ist
geprägt von der Dramatik dieser die
dieser corona-lage dieser steigenden
Zahlen da steigenden Totenzahlen das ist
natürlich ja eine extrem angespannte
aufgeladene Situation hinzu kommt dieser
sich weiter zuspitzende Konflikte auch
gesellschaftliche Spaltung die ja
irgendwie momentan auch viel diskutiert
wird zwischen geimpften und ungeimpften
ich würde aber gerne noch mal auf diesen
erwähnten Punkt zurückkommen und
[Musik]
dagegen halten dass man die die
Persönlichkeit der da zur Wahl stehenden
und jetzt auch gewählten zu sehr
verquickt mit den großen
gesellschaftlichen politischen Problemen
die wir haben also ich glaube man kann
einem Kanzlerkandidat Armin Laschet
nicht die sozusagen die ganze Geschichte
oder die ganze
Problematik der Union vorhalten genauso
ist Annalena baerbock mit ihren Fehlern
im Wahlkampf nicht allein dafür
verantwortlich dass die Grünen
bei dem Ergebnis gelangt sind bei dem
sie gelandet sind und ich meine es ist
ja immerhin das beste Ergebnis der
Grünen und sie regieren jetzt mit und
deswegen glaube ich sozusagen das
psychologisieren allein noch nicht ja
die politische
Personal und Politik oder Programm
wirklich miteinander verquicken
das gehört ja eng zusammen
muss man schon mit Sicherheit also es
werden auch Personen gewählt und ich
glaube bei der Bundestagswahl wird
natürlich auch ein Kanzlerkandidat oder
eine Kanzlerkandidatin gewählt und es
macht einen Unterschied
Werder zur Wahl steht das mit Sicherheit
ich glaube nur dass der Umkehrschluss
nicht funktioniert dass die Schwäche
eines Kandidaten alle Probleme einer
Partei oder noch größer wenn wir es
jetzt eben auf diese corona-lage
spiegeln irgendwie
gesamtgesellschaftliche Probleme
Spiegeln und ich glaube damit macht man
sich es zu einfach und es wäre aus
meiner Sicht auch ein bisschen
Küchenpsychologie
lassen Sie es noch ganz kurz zum Thema
zum Thema Corona was sagen wenn eine
Koalition die Ampel ich rede jetzt von
der ampelkollektion die kommende
Koalition die ja zwar noch keine
politische Verantwortung hat aber die ja
durchaus da schon hätte zeigen können
welche Vorstellungen sie hat bei der
Lösung dieser Krise wenn die schon bei
Corona so in Schlingern gerät siehe
Infektionsschutzgesetz Uneinigkeit in
der Koalition bevor sie überhaupt in die
Regierung gekommen ist was erwarten sie
dann eigentlich bei möglicherweise sehr
viel schwierigeren Projekten noch wie
Klima Energiewende oder Digitalisierung
was sagt das aus über die
Standfestigkeit über die Vertragstreue
aber eben auch über die Krisenfestigkeit
einer kommenden Koalition
also ich sage Ihnen was mir Angst macht
wir haben schwache Kandidaten und sie
wissen das die Lebenserfahrung zeigt uns
das überall schwache Leute holen niemals
starke Leute zu sich und das ist das für
mich die allergrößte Gefahr ein Scholz
wird keine starken Leute in seiner
Regierung haben wollen davon müssen wir
ausgehen so was heißt denn das eine
bärburg die vielleicht Außenministerin
wird da kann ich doch mir nur an den
Kopf fassen sagen
wir haben mit China zu tun wir haben mit
USA zu tun und Frau Beerbaum soll die
Außenpolitik machen
also mir fällt da nichts mehr ein
guter
Politik angeht
sagen muss die Latte die hier Herr Maas
gelegt hat liegt so tief also da kann
man eigentlich nur gewinnen insofern
würde ich jetzt nicht hier von der
Performance von Frau bärburg im Außenamt
was vielleicht
noch mal genauer betrachten ich würde
gerne nur weil es eben aktuell ist noch
mal wegen Corona das ganze oder von der
corona-sicht her diskutieren aber Frau
Wolf sie wollten noch das sagen
ich wollte da ich wollte da einhaken
genau weil
mir die Messe sozusagen der der
Gradmesser der Stärke einer
Persönlichkeit als politische Größe als
politische als politischer Maßstab
missfällt und ich komme in die
ungewöhnliche Situation für mich
ungewöhnliche Situation dass ich die
erwerbende Regierung Verteidiger ist
Journalist ist man ja eigentlich in der
Position eher dass man die kritisiert
aber ich finde man kann ihn
beispielsweise zugute halten dass sie ja
schon versuchen einen neuen politischen
Stil an den Tag zu legen das da eine
andere politische Generation jetzt
Verantwortung übernimmt und wenn man
dieses Argument der der
Persönlichkeit oder der Stärke im
Auftreten einmal umdreht dann war Merkel
ja auch nie die große charismatikerin
nie diejenige die durch ihre
Persönlichkeit durch ihre
Charaktereigenschaft durch ihre
Impulsivität und Leidenschaft Politik
gemacht nicht so trotz 20 16 Jahre
Kanzlerin und auch da kann man vieles
kritisieren in dieser in dieser Amtszeit
aber trotzdem hat sie ja schon für
Stabilität und Kontinuität gesorgt die
ja ganz offensichtlich in der Person
Scholz wieder gewählt wurde das wurde
klang ja vorher schon an also ich glaube
mit Scholz wurde in gewisser Weise auch
ein weiter so gewählt wenn man so will
und deswegen funktioniert für mich diese
Kategorie einer einer charismatischen
Führungspersönlichkeit noch gar nicht
zumal wir ja noch nicht gesehen haben
wie die regieren die sollen jetzt
erstmal gewählt werden Scholz als
Kanzler und ins Amt kommen und dann kann
man diese Kategorie vielleicht noch mal
aufziehen also einerseits weiter so
Scholz aber auch neuer politische Stil
die These von Frau Wolf naja was heißt
denn Stil ich muss da in zwei Punkten
sehr widersprechen ich würde mir das ja
auch liebe Frau Wolf sehr wünschen dass
die Frage der Persönlichkeit nicht die
Bedeutung hätte das können wir uns aus
puristischen Gründen aus Gründen einer
Programmatik auch Gründen einer
inhaltlichen Unterscheidbarkeit die in
den letzten Jahren gerade in Zeiten
unserer Koalition immer zu kurz gekommen
ist wir können uns programmatische
Fragen größer denken wo ich übrigens
aber auch das zweite Problem sehe dass
gerade eine SPD hochgradig unter
konturiert ist gerade was die
Energiewende anbelangt es fehlt ja auch
programmatisch vieles aber wir dürfen
doch eines nicht verkennen in Zeiten der
Krise wie den unsere in den riesige
Probleme ich würde behaupten größere
Probleme als je in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Anliegen haben wir es bei
allen Wahlen ob es Landtagswahlen waren
und andere Waren gesehen dass die Flucht
zu der starken Person und das
vertrauensmoment um einer überzeugenden
Persönlichkeit einer auch Figur mit
Führungsfähigkeit und einen zweiten
Punkt gerade angesichts der riesigen
Probleme auch mit leidenschaftlicher
Überzeugungsfähigkeit absolut essentiell
ist und deshalb glaube ich es geht es
greift es zu kurz dass wir gerade jetzt
nicht enorm darauf abstellen müssen
zumal noch ein zweites und das macht es
Kardinal anders als im Falle von Angela
Merkel bei der wir nie vergessen dürfen
dass sie in ihre Autorität über 16 Jahre
hereingewachsen ist am Anfang war von
Autorität nichts zu spüren das will ich
deutlich machen und trotzdem hatte sie
im Unterschied wenn Sie den Namen
bärbock schon bringen immerhin schon
acht Jahre als Ministerin auf dem Buckel
sie hat die cdu-krise nach Helmut Kohl
gemeistert sie hat vor allem sich gegen
härtesten Widerstand durchgesetzt das
waren alles Dinge die Frau behrburg
nicht mitbrachte und trotzdem musste sie
in die Autorität hereinwachsen und die
ganz große Hypothek dieser neuen
Koalition um auf diese immer wieder
benannten Stilfragen zu kommen die sich
als eine Farce ich mache es mal sehr
deutlich entpuppt haben das steht der
Stil die neue Stilfrage darin bestand
das grüne und gelbe mit selfies
aufgetreten sind und sich geschwört
haben dass nichts dass kein Blatt Papier
zwischen sie passt war eine völlige
Verkennung kardinaler Unterschiede und
die große Führungsfrage einer solchen
Koalition drei dreierparteien die wir
abgesehen von der Anfangsphase der
Bundesrepublik nie hatten wird für den
führenden Politiker nämlich Olaf Scholz
bedeuten dass er eine Führungsfähigkeit
und Leidenschaftlichkeit besitzt die das
Volk aber auch diese Koalitionäre
mitnimmt das ist eine Führungsaufgabe
die weit über das hinausgeht was eine
klassische zweierkoalition zu leisten
hatte weil es weit weit diametral
auseinandergehendere Kräfte sind
insofern braucht es umso mehr eine
überzeugende leidenschaftliche
führungsstarke Persönlichkeit so leicht
ist mir tut geht um Integration um die
Fähigkeit eine Koalition zu führen es
geht aber auch um Glaubwürdigkeit denn
ich habe es vorhin schon angedeutet
möglicherweise müssen noch zwei ganz
unpopuläre Entscheidungen getroffen
werden im nächsten Wochen eine
Impfpflicht und das was man ja
eigentlich nicht mehr wollte einen
Lockdown der ja nicht nur den Leuten auf
die Nerven geht sondern der auch soziale
und wirtschaftliche Konsequenzen oder
auch Schäden zur Folge haben kann
wie ist das mit der Glaubwürdigkeit in
dieser neuen Koalition dann das muss ja
auch dann nicht nur
erlassen werden als politische Maßnahme
man muss ja auch Verständnis und
Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung
einwerfen ja das wird sehr schwierig man
muss ja dann doch Positionen abräumen
die man teilweise gestern noch bezogen
hat also Herr Söder ist daran ja Meister
darin hat also praktisch den Ehering
aber nicht Mitglieder abgegeben
Ehrentitel drehhofer von seinem
Vorgänger geerbt aber das sieht man ja
auch auf anderer Ebene auch dass eben
Frau Frau Frau Merkel und Frau Merkel
beispielsweise oder aber auch ersparen
gesagt haben wird keine Impfpflicht
geben Klammer auf solange wir was zu
sagen haben Klammern zu also könnte es
theoretisch jetzt eine geben ich würde
es dennoch für die Vollendung eines
stolperstaates halten wenn man die FDP
jetzt gewisse Maßen die Pistole auf die
Brust setzen würde und sagen muss aha
pandemische epidemische Lage wird doch
verlängert warte immer dagegen letzten
zwei Jahre Morgengabe auf dem
friedenstisch der der ampelregierung
stimmt dem zu und als zweiten
Impfpflicht muss jetzt doch kommen
sofern glaube ich die epidemische Lage
wird Auslaufen das Instrumentarium was
Angela Merkel möglicherweise heute Abend
noch versucht hat mit den vier
Parteivorsitzenden der Ampel ich war
nicht dabei ich gehe davon aus dass es
trotzdem
ausgehen dass sie trotzdem dass sie
trotzdem eben auslaufen lassen wird was
ist denn das für ein Stadt wenn man sich
als vor der Vorgängerregierung sagen
lässt oder überzeugendes was man zu tun
habe ich persönlich als auch für gut
dass sie eben damit epidemische Lage
ausfällt ich würde sagen da müsste und
sollte jetzt auch die Ampel daran
festhalten was die Impfpflicht angeht
ist viel schwieriger weil dort Zukunft
natürlich von den Ländern ungleich höher
ist und wirklich hier primär der der
Bund gefragt ist aber es werden beides
Fällen wenn es eben Positionen die nur
mit einem Gesichtsverlust namentlich der
FDP zu erhalten werden und dazu ist
eigentlich der FDP nicht zu raten naja
aber es geht darum eine noch viel
dramatischere Frage die Tatsache dass
die epidemische Lage so dramatisch zu
werden droht das all die Maßnahmen die
die amplisten die die ampelkoalitionäre
jetzt gerade ausgeschlossen haben schon
Anfang Dezember wieder und noch
drastischer auf dem Tablett stehen auf
dem Tape stehen das heißt das ist die
Gefahr dieser Koalition die kognitive
Dissonanz des wünscht dir was wir wollen
es aussetzen mit gutem Willen es gab ja
auch demokratietheoretisch gute Gründe
dafür zu sagen man hat will damit
deutlich machen das wird nicht auf ewig
verlängert aber man rennt faktisch in
die Falle dass man damit einen Status
geschaffen hat den man in Kürze wieder
Abrollen muss und das ist ja auch weil
wir den Namen Söder ins Feld geführt
haben die ungemeine Raffinesse von Herrn
Söder
übrigens auch von Herrn Spahn das muss
man deutlich sagen Herr Spahn hat ja
gewissermaßen die Ampel in die Falle
gelockt er war derjenige sagte wir
lassen es Auslaufen die ampelisten waren
begeistert haben gesagt ja großartig wir
springen darauf ein jetzt sagt aber vor
allem Söder ich nehme meine alle alte
Rolle des Team Vorsicht an herr
Kretschmann tritt ihn zur Seite und
propagiert eine Impfpflicht was
natürlich noch ein weit weiter
dramatischerer Akt ist der dann aber
eines Tages für diese Ampel so
Durchsetzung steht das heißt das
Abräumen der nationalen Notlage der
epidemischen Notlage von nationaler
Tragweite ist ja ein Nullung das ist
jetzt hart aber nichts verglichen mit
dem was uns mit einer Einführung einer
Impfpflicht entgegenkommt das wird eine
Polarisierung in diesem Lande
erforderlich
das ist dramatisch weil und da wird dann
die Führungskraft kommt
mittlerweile ich halte das übrigens auch
wirklich wie hoch bedenklich weil er aus
einem Grund es mag der das große
Versäumnis die dann besteht und darin
das große Versäumnis vor allem der noch
letzten also der jetzt noch
kommissarisch amtierende Regierung die
er tatsächlich den gesamten Sommer
verschlafen hat übrigens natürlich auch
wie die Landesregierung für dazu dass
diese neue Ampel eine ungeheure Hypothek
aufgesetzt bekommt aufgetischt bekommt
die dazu führt dass man jetzt in
Absicherung von Verhältnismäßigkeit man
hätte im Sommer viel viel mehr machen
müssen man könnte wahrscheinlich erst
einmal das jetzt Olaf Scholz mitnehmen
wird völlig egal
ich würde trotzdem ganz gerne noch mal
den Aspekt auf etwas anderes lenken
nehme ich auf den den Koalitionsvertrag
und Herr turborg wir haben über Olaf
Scholz schon gesprochen sie haben das ja
vorhin auch gesagt
er war ich sag das gerade eben ja schon
Mitglied der alten Regierung als
Vizekanzler er wird jetzt Bundeskanzler
werden also er sozusagen das Kontinuum
im Übergang auch hätte er aus ihrer
Sicht jetzt auch per Frage von Führung
von Kompetenz von Persönlichkeit diesen
Übergang viel mehr als Person Olaf
Scholz als politische Persönlichkeit
gestalten müssen
ja natürlich er ist doch das Bindeglied
zwischen der alten und dem neuen
Regierung wenn der wirklich eine starke
Persönlichkeit wäre dann hätte er doch
die beiden Seiten in dieser coronazeit
zusammengebracht und die hätten hinter
verschlossenen Türen Lösung gesucht und
hoffentlich auch gefunden aber so wie
das jetzt gelaufen ist zeigt doch die
ganze Schwäche dieser Ampelkoalition in
personifiziert durch haben
durch Herrn Scholz
Frau Wolf wir haben sie haben gerade
schon gesagt es gibt einen neuen Stil
zumindestens in der Art wie die
ampelkoalitionäre in der Sondierung in
den Koalitionsgesprächen aufgetreten
sind sie waren ja eigentlich sehr
zurückhaltend mit Auftritten auch
was wir jetzt schon wissen wir wissen
noch nicht alles was den
Koalitionsvertrag vor allem die
Ressortverteilung angeht aber gab es da
nicht auch die oder gibt es jetzt die
Situation dass ich einer auf Kosten des
anderen profiliert hat
ja das ist insofern tatsächlich schwer
zu beantworten weil man eben so dicht
gehalten hat weil man dieses Credo der
Diskretion der Vertraulichkeit der
Gespräche so hoch gehängt hat und umso
mehr wird dann natürlich in das
hineingeheimnis was man dann weiß ich
glaube was man schon sagen kann ist dass
die FDP eine ziemlich starke Position in
diesem Verhandlungen hat nach allem was
was man weiß was man hört läuft er
darauf hinaus dass Christian Lindner
tatsächlich das Finanzministerium für
sich beansprucht damit einen
wichtiges Ressort vor allem angesichts
der Zukunftsaufgaben von Klimaschutz
über
Digitalisierung bis hin zu ja
transformationsaufgaben der Erneuerung
des Staates also da ist einfach das
Finanzministerium ein Angelpunkt die
Grünen hingegen glaube ich haben selbst
ihren Anteil daran dass sie als relativ
schwach in den Verhandlungen
genommen werden weil sie als am
stärksten die Hürden und Schwierigkeiten
der Verhandlungen nach außen getragen
haben also Annalena baerbock sagte jetzt
am Wochenende bei der brandenburgischen
bei den brandenburgischen grünen erneut
es waren auch Situationen in denen sie
die Nase voll gehabt hätten der
Bundesgeschäftsführer der Grünen wählt
zu Worte wie das ein extrem brutale oder
brutale anstrengend war war die Wortwahl
also die Grünen haben ihren Anteil daran
dass man sie als kennenzulernen
schwachen Partner jetzt könnte man ja
sagen Koalitionsverhandlungen sind keine
Kaffeekränzchen also wenn ich sie jetzt
richtig verstehe die FDP hat clever
Beute gemacht und die Grünen stehen
möglicherweise mit halbleeren Händen da
genau aber das ist eben genau die Frage
also Obst dann tatsächlich so kommt das
wird meine beurteilen können wenn dir
das vorverteilung feststeht und wenn der
Koalitionsvertrag fest steht aber da
weiß man noch zu wenig um das wirklich
sozusagen inhaltlich sagen zu können
aber was man auf jeden Fall weiß ist ja
eher so atmosphärische
Momente und da hat die FDP mehr sich
selbst als starke starke Partner am
Verhandlungstisch dargestellt und die
Grünen mehr die Hürden und
Schwierigkeiten kommuniziert
da geht es ja auch um
Durchsetzungsfähigkeit ist ja auch ein
wesentliches führungs- und
persönlichkeitselement dass ich da die
FDP durchsetzt obwohl sie der kleinste
Partner ist gegen die Grünen lag das
möglicherweise auch daran dass die
Erwartungshaltung bei den Grünen zu groß
war dass die Grünen vielleicht auch ihre
Forderungen zu hoch geschraubt haben
schon im Wahlkampf exakt das über
politische Führung auch über den Einsatz
der eigenen Kompetenz aus
also die Grünen haben natürlich das
große Problem gehabt dass Frau Frau
beerburg sich gleich in den ersten
Wochen quasi disqualifizierter die kam
ja sehr schnell nicht mehr in Frage als
Kandidatin und der
FDP-Chef der Linde er hat der hat das
sehr sehr smart gemacht und er weiß ja
genau ohne uns die FDP also ich rede
jetzt nicht für mich sondern für Lindner
und seine Partei
könnt ihr die Regierung nicht bilden und
das hat er sehr geschickt gemacht ich
habe ihn ja also im Wahlkampf trat er
teilweise auch sehr smart auf muss ich
sagen
insofern ja der hat die Grünen ich will
nicht sagen ausgetrickst dass das wäre
jetzt ich bin ja nirgendwo dabei gewesen
aber eindeutig macht eine bessere Figur
als die Grünen sind natürlich auch ein
wenig über diese Zweiteilung die
nachführen nicht geklärt ist gestolpert
und dann sagt immer der cdu-werke
gespalten die andere Parteien auch
wirklich gespalten sind eigentlich wenn
man die Kluft anschaut zwischen
beispielsweise grüner Jugend und
mehrheitsjugend zwischen dem
weltretterpartus und der pragmatischen
Leidenschaft fürs Regieren die Grünen
also wenn man sich zum Beispiel das
Klimaschutz Sofortprogramm anschaut vom
August diesen Jahr dieses Jahres erst da
wird sich das wenigste im
Koalitionsvertrag mutmaßlich
wiederfinden was man heute hört haben
sie offenbar den Kohleausstieg bis 2030
vorgesetzt es werden Sie jetzt wie eine
Trophäe am Skalp präsentieren aber die
stark gestiegene Fraktion der Grünen
Jugend beispielsweise im Bundestag wird
weit müsste eigentlich weite Teile des
Koalitionsvertrages will ein bisschen
erkennen ablehnen sie hat also kein
Tempolimit drin die Reduktion der
öffentlichen Bauten findet mutmaßlich
nicht statt die Verkehrswende wird
abgemildert insofern glaube ich die
Grünen haben wirklich das Problem dass
sie mit einem mit dem allergrößten
Pathos angetreten sind nämlich wenn wir
nicht maximale Forderungen durchsetzen
dann ist praktisch die Apokalypse
ausgerufen und das müssten Sie jetzt
eigentlich konzentrieren ohne pathose
sie auch die FDP nicht
angetriebenes Problem das geht nicht nur
um die des Pathos es geht um zwei Dinge
es geht um die Frage was sind die
Ansprüche die man tatsächlich als Partei
in einem solchen Koalitionsvertrag
unterbringen will und wenn in diesem
Koalitionsvertrag zwei andere Akteure
nämlich die FDP zuerst sie haben es
gesagt ganz Kardinal sagt so wir wollen
unsere Grundforderung kein Tempolimit
keine Bürgerversicherung also keine
Zusammenlegung von privater und
gesetzlicher Krankenkasse keine neuen
Schulden und als letztes keine Steuerung
wir bringen das alles durch dann ist
ihre wederschaft bedient die SPD hat es
sich genauso
gestalten genau das genau das und die
SPD hat es sich ähnlich leicht gemacht
die SPD hat gesagt ach wir bringen
unsere zweikardinalen Versprechungen 12
Euro Mindestlohn und sichere Renten
durch die Grünen haben das große Problem
dass sie allein gelassen werden mit dem
Anspruch den der vermeintliche
klimakanzler Olaf Scholz im Wahlkampf
noch viele Monstranz vor sich
hergetragen hat ich setze mich für die
Klimapolitik ein danach war dafür nichts
mehr zu spielen und dieses große Problem
dass hier drei Parteien am Start sind
von den zwei ihre
Pfunde bereits untergebracht haben ihre
klientel-interessen also SPD wie FDP
aber die Grünen ein Stück weit mit dem
viel viel größeren und das hat nicht nur
mit Pathos zu tun das ist die Größe der
Aufgabe die Sie sich vorgenommen haben
als gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe
begreifen dass sie damit im Regen stehen
gelassen werden ist ein Grundproblem
dieser gesamten Koalition und auch das
ein Problem was maximal für Minecraft
auf einen Kanzler Scholz letztlich ein
Stück weit zurückführt wenn er muss auch
in diesem Feld für diese gesamte
Koalition einen grünen fadenspinnen
sonst wird das ganze Projekt an die Wand
fahren
was hat das jetzt für Auswirkungen
wenn jetzt also die Grünen die mit dem
ja mit dem größten Vorschusslorbeeren
gestartet sind die das meiste gefordert
haben die am stärksten diesen Anspruch
fortschrittskoalition Aufbruch zu neuen
Ufern verkörpert haben wenn die jetzt
sozusagen das Gefühl haben sie seien
eigentlich hinten runtergefallen was
bedeutet das für die Stabilität
und die Berechenbarkeit der Ampel
na ich würde gerne ehe ich zu dieser
Partei
politischen Logik komme einmal noch mal
auf den Punkt kommen dass die Grünen
natürlich am stärksten einfach ein
faktisches Problem beschrieben haben
nämlich die Dringlichkeit von mehr
Klimaschutz und die Dringlichkeit die
Erderwärmung zu begrenzen das ist
politisch ein extrem dickes Brett aber
man kann den Grünen durchaus zu Gute
halten dass sie dieses Problem und die
Dringlichkeit dieses Problems einfach am
klarsten benannt haben
Olaf Scholz hat in dicken Lettern
klimakanzler auf Wahlplakate geschrieben
hat aber im Gegensatz zu den Grünen sehr
viel weniger proaktiv dieses Thema auch
angenommen und vermutlich würde auch ein
Teufel tun dieses Thema zu sehr an sich
oder an seine Partei zu ziehen weil da
die Gefahr des Scheiterns extrem groß
ist weil die Aufgabe riesig ist und
bisher viel vers spannend ist ob das
beim Ausbau der Erneuerbaren ist bei
Infrastrukturen beim Schienenausbau also
extrem viel Nachholbedarf was ist jetzt
für die Grünen bedeutet ich meine man
hat ja gemerkt dass die versuchen genau
diese Hürde zu überspringen indem sie zu
indem sie sagen Klimaschutz ist nicht
nur eine Aufgabe der Grünen sondern
aller Koalitionspartner sowohl FDP als
auch SPD halten das schön von sich aber
ich glaube wenn diese diese Koalition
wirklich dieses sehr sehr hoch gehängte
Versprecher einer fortschrittskoalition
auch nur anernd erfüllen will dann muss
sie den Klimaschutz anpacken und dann
muss sie auch die Digitalisierung
anpacken jenseits von
parteipolitischen
[Musik]
taktierereien sozusagen und das glaube
ich lässt sich insofern ein Stück weit
auch auf die corona-krise übertragen
weil diese Probleme einfach diese Krisen
so groß und umfassend sind dass es dann
nicht nur mit
parteilogik funktioniert wenn die Grünen
jetzt das Gefühl haben die Bündnis grün
dass sie da möglicherweise zu kurz
gekommen sind was muss der Bundeskanzler
denn Olaf Scholz dann machen um da
wieder zu einem Ausgleich zu führen
damit es eben nicht von Anfang an mit
der Hypothek belastet ist zwei haben
sich da gegenseitig die wichtigsten
Sachen zugeschoben und die Nummer drei
also in dem Fall die Bündnis Grünen die
ja in Wirklichkeit die Nummer Zwei sind
was die Stärke angeht sind da leer oder
halbleer ausgegangen oder wieder
streiten sich eben die beiden
klassischen Funktionen eines Kanzlers in
der Koalition hat die
Richtlinienkompetenz da bin ich auch
sehr gespannt wie er die ausüben wird
weil letztendlich muss er dann diese
Streitfragen ja auch im Sinne lösen dass
sie für das ganze Kabinett sprechfähig
sind und andererseits muss er natürlich
drei disparate Parteien nicht nur bei
bei Laune halten sondern wie beim
rheinländischen sagen man muss auch
gönnen können also man muss eben auch
sein seinen Vorhof seinen Vorgärten
statt können indem wir dann auch glänzen
kann indem er die Blumen seines Wunsches
Pflanzen kann und das große Problem ist
ja momentan sehe ich das eben Scholz
selber als Person im Wahlkampf aber auch
durch sein Programm einfach zu wenig
fassbar geblieben ist als dass man in
einem guten guter Zuversicht sagen
konnte diese Richtlinienkompetenz wird
er so ausführen dass dennoch alle
Partner gleichzeitig ihr eigenes Feld
besetzen können das wäre die große Kunst
und wenn das nicht gelingt wenn wir also
Anfang an ein oder zwei Parteien haben
die also Grummeln am Kabinettstisch
sitzen und dem anderen vorwerfen dass
man die tollen eigenen Pläne boykottiert
hat dann werden es wirklich schlechte
Zeiten für Deutschland aber ich bin
heute noch nicht bereit den Stab zu
brechen über die ampelregierung so eine
Dreierkoalition also aus drei
eigenständigen Parteien werden ja bisher
auch schon eine sondern auch drei
eigenständige Parteien wo zwei relativ
eng beieinander waren die Union aber
drei wirklich unabhängige die jetzt mehr
oder minder auch durch das Wahlergebnis
zusammengezogen worden sind ist das
einfach in der deutschen politischen
Praxis auch noch nicht so
gang und gäbe wie man damit umgeht
jemand ein Ausgleich schafft wie man
auch versucht das erfolgreich zu kriegen
also die Quadratur des Kreises manchmal
dass es da am Anfang noch ziemlich viel
Ladehemmung geben wird weil das eben
etwas Neues in der Politik ist und damit
auch etwas Neues für Olaf Scholz für
Christian Lindner absolut wir haben das
nur in den Anfangsjahren der
Bundesrepublik gehabt aber jetzt kommt
ein entscheidender Punkt dazu damals
waren die Unterschiede die die Parteien
davor ausgemacht haben nicht so
ausgeprägt wie sie es heute sind denn
das erschwerende ist doch dass die FDP
völlig andere Politikangebote und
Versprechen gemacht hat die FDP hat eine
Klimapolitik versprochen Klimapolitik in
Anführungszeichen ohne jede
verzichtslogik ohne jede Einschränkung
ohne jede Umverteilung das heißt es ist
eine völlig diametral andere Politik die
die Grünen eigentlich verheißen haben
und zum Teil auch übrigens die SPD und
wenn man das unter einen Hut bringen
will das haben wir jetzt exemplarisch
übrigens auch ein Beispiel Corona
gezeigt bekommen die FDP wollte absolut
Freiheit völlig individualistisch aus
der corona-krise rausspringen die Grünen
waren weit mehr bereit wir haben es ja
gemerkt bei der Frage der Impfpflicht
für Betroffene Berufe zu sagen gewissen
Konzession machen den
solidaritätsgedanken größer fassen wenn
diese Parteien so enorm
auseinanderdriften dann ist es mit dem
Bestellen des hier eigenen Gartens nicht
getan dann muss die jeweils eine Partei
aus Gründen der Vernunft auch zum Teil
springen und die große Frage wird sein
sind die Parteien in sich so stark dass
sie sagen können ja wir haben uns aus
Vernunftgründen für eine gemeinsame
Lösung entschieden wir springen zum Teil
über unseren Schatten wir machen
Konzession bei Corona ist es ja ein
Stück weit gelungen die FDP hat ihre
Position in den letzten Wochen hätte es
beobachtet haben fast maximal verändert
unter dem Druck der Ereignisse bei der
Klimakrise ist es viel schwieriger weil
die Klimakrise nicht in der absoluten
rabiazeit durch Todeszahlen die uns
jeden Tag im zufügen in Zukunft noch
erlebbar sein werden es ist nicht so
drastisch das heißt man wird
wahrscheinlich weiter hart um seine
eigenes Terra um seine eigenen
versprechen kämpfen und dann liegt es
umso mehr und das ist die große
kardinalaufgabe es liegt an Olaf Scholz
und ich bin auf diese
Regierungserklärung auf die erste
Regierungserklärung die wir erleben
werden da geht es noch gar nicht mal um
Richtlinienkompetenz da geht es
überhaupt erst einmal um den großen
Gesamtentwurf gelingt es dem Kanzler ein
Aufschlag zu machen der deutlich macht
ich bin auf der Höhe der Herausforderung
und ich mache ein echtes Angebot was für
die gesamte Koalition spricht das ist
glaube ich die erste kardinalaufgabe und
da ist niemand so sehr gefordert wie der
Kanzler und wie man muss springen sie
haben gesagt eine Partei wird springen
müssen und dass wir wirklich der der
Lackmustest dann für die
Regierungsfähigkeit wer als erstes
bereit ist aus Souveränität auch zu
springen und für das größere ganze etwas
abzugeben im Moment ohne sich als
dauerhafter Verlierer zu fühlen
der Vorstandsvorsitzende eines
Wirtschaftsunternehmens oder der CEO wie
man jetzt so schön sagt der hat ja
Richtlinienkompetenz er führt das
Unternehmen er ist auch für Erfolg oder
Misserfolg dann verantwortlich der
Bundeskanzler hat zwar diese in der
Verfassung verbrieft der
Richtlinienkompetenz aber ist jetzt
gerade schon gehört die wird ja sehr
stark relativiert sind drei Parteien in
der Koalition die SPD hat nicht sehr
stark abgeschnitten noch nie hat eine
Partei mit nur 25% der Stimmen
Bundeskanzler gestellt man muss auf
vieles Rücksicht nehmen es ist ein
unglaublicher Wandlungsprozess da was
bedeutet das für einen Bundeskanzler
wenn er als Chef eines Gremiums diese
Richtlinienkompetenz nicht mehr so
richtig
ausüben kann was wie muss er dann führen
was wie muss er da reagieren
also mit Herrn Scholz werden wir zwei
Probleme haben das eine Problem ist ein
verkörpert ja nicht die SPD das wissen
wir ja deswegen verhält er sich ja auch
so ruhig und das zweite sie brauchen
ungeheure integrative Fähigkeiten um
diese drei Parteien zusammenzuführen und
zusammenzuhalten ich glaube schon dass
die Parteien jetzt gerne eine
Legislative ein Legislaturperiode
regieren wollen aber wir haben mit Herrn
Scholz und wir werden das ja sehen nicht
diese großartige Persönlichkeit die
genau das kann
integrativ wirken er kann ja keine
Instruktion rausgeben er hat er muss
überzeugen und er muss die Parteien
zusammenführen das ist er nicht nach
neuen Verständnis ist er das einfach
nicht das hätte er zeigen können und er
zeigt es nicht deswegen also ich würde
auf die
diese Koalition die nächsten Jahre nicht
wetten wollen Frau Wolf wenn man sich
anzieht wer da jetzt ins Kabinett
einziehen wird einige Namen sind noch
unklar da wird noch spekuliert aber klar
ist natürlich neben Olaf Scholz Anna
Lena behrburg Robert Habeck Christian
Lindner noch einige andere
Volker Wissing zum Beispiel von der FDP
hat und hohe Freitag katrin
Göring-Eckardt von den Grünen werden da
genannt werden wahrscheinlich im
Kabinett auch sein Svenja Schulze und
Hubertus Heil von der SPD und Christine
Lambrecht also das sind jetzt so die wo
man sagen kann möglicherweise sind die
gesetzt da sind ja zum Teil auch
durchaus starke Persönlichkeiten dabei
die vor allen Dingen immer das eigene
Fortkommen im Blick hatten also eher
solo-darsteller sind als Teamworker wen
braucht denn jetzt oder wie muss das
Kabinett beschaffen sein dass Olaf
Scholz diese Aufgabe die Herr turburg da
gerade beschrieben hat auch umsetzen
kann dass die Koalition nicht sofort bei
der ersten größeren Krise Schiffbruch
erleidet
ja die Namen die sie jetzt aufgezählt
haben das sind ja interessanterweise
alles sehr bekannte Namen sei es weil
sie im bisherigen Kabinett waren oder
weil sie wie Herr Hofreiter und Frau
Göring-Eckardt Fraktionsvorsitzende
waren insofern sind das alles schon sehr
politisch erfahrene
Persönlichkeiten das was die
Ampelkoalition zum Start ja versucht hat
und was ja auch Olaf Scholz jetzt in
allen öffentlichen Auftritten die zwar
wenige sind aber die die wenigen
sozusagen was man aus denen entnehmen
kann ja versucht ist dass sie sich ein
narrativ geben das sind dann eben diese
diese Schlagworte der
fortschrittskoalition des
modernisierungs Jahrzehnts auch dieser
Begriff auch in den die Union den stark
geprägt hat aber viel Aufbruch
Erneuerung all das also man versucht
sozusagen die
Differenzen die es zwischen den
einzelnen Parteien gibt mit so einem
großen gemeinsamen narrativ
du zusammenzufassen
ich würde dann noch mal dagegen halten
wir kamen ja daher eine Diskussion dass
das an einzelnen Persönlichkeiten sich
fest macht und ich glaube der große
Unterschied zu CEO und Unternehmens oder
wirtschaftslogiken ist eben dass es
durchaus auch andere Motivationen gibt
wieso Politiker und Politikerinnen in
die Politik gehen und diesen Weg dann
einschlagen eben nicht weil es irgendwie
nur um um ja irgendwie
profitlogiken und materielle
diesen Idealismus möchte aber das ist
gut gemeint wenn ich dazu was sagen darf
das sind ja alles Floskeln entschuldigen
sie bitte Modernisierung die ganzen
Sachen Innovation das sind ein großes
floskelgewitter was wir bisher gehört
haben die nicht sind außer Überschriften
die nichts bedeuten das einzige und da
würde ich Ihnen auch noch mal sehr
widersprechen der einzige ganz große
Vorteil von Olaf Scholz ist der dass er
der einzige Routinier in diesem Kabinett
neben den gestandenen spd-ministern
Hubertus Heil wir haben es zwar bei
Politikern zu tun hybridika wieder seit
Jahren kennen aber weder Christian
Lindner noch Annalena baerbock noch die
ganze grünen Riege hat überhaupt
Regierungserfahrung gehabt der einzige
ist Robert Habeck der hat mal das
Landwirtschaftsminister
Schleswig-Holstein gelehrt das heißt wir
haben es mit einer Regierung von
Greenhorns zu tun mit Anfängern die sehr
viel damit zu tun haben während ihre
eigenen Ministerien zu leiten und das
ist vielleicht die größte Chance für
Olaf Scholz dass er derjenige ist der
aus einer großen Erfahrung schöpfen kann
und von daher sicherlich eine eigene
Souveränität entfalten kann aber das ist
vielleicht auch die einzige die ich
immer noch eine für einen Satzende Frage
Sendung wir können nichts mehr Neues
anfangen Alexander Kessler learning by
doing für die neue Regierung bitte einen
Antwortsatz learning auf jeden Fall wir
sind noch im Bereich der Lyrik es wird
die Prosa des alltagsbeginn und wir
sollten die Ampel nicht so früh
abschreiben dann bedanke ich mich bei
Albrecht von Lucke Alexander Kissler bei
Heiner dorburg und bei Jana Wolf liebe
Zuschauer morgen in der phönix-runde ja
wir warten auf die neuen Ereignisse
morgen entweder gibt es etwas Neues
Impfpflicht und Lockdown die
Krisensitzung im Kanzleramt heute Abend
oder wir haben einen neuen
Koalitionsvertrag auf jeden Fall morgen
eines dieser beiden Themen in der
phönix-runde jetzt folgt Phoenix der Tag
mit Michael krons und auch da ist das
Thema Impfpflicht ein wichtiges Thema
heute viele Äußerungen in einer längeren
Zusammenfassung jetzt bei Phoenix
bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]